Hoy es Día de rezo en este templo
dedicado al candomblé es una religión
que llegó a Brasil de la mano de los más
de 5 millones de esclavos africanos
estamos en la mallada fluminencia la
periferia de Río de Janeiro donde reina
el miedo tras una ola de ataques contra
Terreros como son llamados esos templos
A quién no baiguazú hubo un número muy
grande de depredaciones de invasiones y
de asesinatos también hubo un pay de
santo que fue asesinado en la Favela de
Nova Brasilia el 78% de los sacerdotes
de las religiones afro sufrió algún tipo
de violencia de hecho tres denuncias por
intolerancia religiosa son formalizadas
en Brasil cada día solo en el primer
semestre de 2022 fueron
a pocos minutos de aquí un terreiro Fue
totalmente destruido por un grupo de
narcotraficantes
a la religión evangélica
son personas que dicen no quiero que el
viva más aquí
ahora quién vive aquí es Dios
Esta religiosa da voz a quienes están
amenazados de muerte hizo una maestría
en psicosociología sobre el crecimiento
de ataques religiosos en su región a
pesar de su perfil militante reconoce
que tiene miedo
mis amigos me dicen hermana
los ataques déjalo los narco evangélicos
no son los únicos responsables de las
agresiones para este estudioso detrás de
la intolerancia religiosa está el
racismo estructural
Este es un proyecto de estado un
proyecto político hegemónico que quiere
que los cristianos sean hegemónicos
que sean una comunidad con todos sus
derechos mientras que las otras regiones
como el espiritismo la humana y el
candomblé están fuera de ese proyecto
para luchar contra este fenómeno en 2006
fue creada en San Pablo la de crady una
división especial de la policía
especializadas en crímenes raciales y
religiosos
Posteriormente la década fue implantada
en otras ciudades como Río de Janeiro y
Salvador de bahía que junto a San Pablo
registran el mayor número de agresiones
contra religiones afro
según esta comisaria internet permitió
que se disparase el número de ataques
pero también brindo anonimato aquellas
víctimas con miedo de denunciar el
trámite puede ser realizado en cualquier
unidad de la policía Pero existe también
la comisaría electrónica que además se
encarga de los crímenes contra los lgbt
Entonces si la víctima no quiere venir
hasta aquí No importa ella denuncia por
internet y se tomarán providencias en
relaciones su queja el trabajo
investigativo de la policía funciona
como elemento disuasorio pero no
consigue frenar las agresiones que el
año pasado aumentaron un 45%
Nelson que trabaja desde hace 18 años
con esos delitos ha comprobado que la
intolerancia religiosa a menudo se
mezcla con el machismo y la homofobia A
diferencia de otras regiones
la umbanda y el candomble formas
primeras fueron las primeras en tener
mujeres como líderes
líderes ven como además de homosexuales
y negros negros de que se tiene
prejuicio
es la religión de los collares que se
usan en la umbanda y en el candom pues
contra el liderazgo de una mujer el
empoderamiento de esta mujer el
empoderamiento de este negro o de este
homosexual para este policía los narco
evangélicos que destruyen los templos en
Río de Janeiro representan una excepción
dentro del panorama nacional lo más
habitual son las ofensas verbales o a
través de las redes sociales
en Río de Janeiro un sector de los
evangélicos se opone a esta violencia
[Música]
clever es una estrella de la música
gospel cantó en la investidura del
presidente Lula
Soy amigo de los macumbbeiros
de vez en cuando los fieles con sus
tambores aparecen aquí en mi iglesia y
está todo bien
en la mesa de Cristo cabe todo el mundo
su apoyo explícito a las religiones de
matriz africana le ha costado varios
ataques por parte de sus fans
concretamente una vez que canto en un
terreno devastado y reconstruido con la
ayuda de algunos pastores evangélicos
antes de ser un pastor antes de ser un
cristiano Soy un hombre negro que creció
en una Favela yo fui criado en un
ambiente muy plural desde el momento en
que veo en la sociedad siendo una figura
pública templos atacados Víctimas de la
intolerancia religiosa no puedo quedarme
callado es el ejemplo vivo de que no
todos los evangélicos son intolerantes
ni se identifican con el fundamentalismo
religioso